（もう始めますか？）ん？うん
（はい）
（それでは そろそろ再開いたします）
（よろしくお願いいたします）
はい では
2番目のテーマに入ります
これは まあ
そんなに難しくはないと思いますね
これは［self-compassion］
「自分を大事にする」というテーマなんですね
まあ
話す価値は ないと思いますけどね
［理性のある人は自分を大切にする］
で いろいろ経典でね
「自分をどうすれば大切にするのか」…
「自分を大切にする正しいやり方は何なのか」
とか たくさん経典があります
まあ 結構たくさんありますよ
だから引用することっていうのは
ちょっと難しい
はい
これは 何で…
自分を大切にすることを
テーマにしてほしがるのか 分からないんだけど
世の中は 変人いっぱいですからね
常識がない人々ばっかりですね
人は常識がないと もう…
自分のことを大切にしてないでしょう？
ですから 私の答えは至って簡単 単純で
［Be normal］
普通になりなさいよ と
普通の人間になりなさいよ と
［人は素直ではありません］
みんな カッコつけてるんですね
何か よろいをかぶってるんです
何か 妄想概念を持って
それが自分だ と思って 生活するんだから
気持ち悪くてしょうがないんです
人と仲良くすることも
できなくなるんですよ だから…
何か 変な妄想概念
あれこれと
例えば 自分のことを
人が勝手に いろんな判断してしまって
その色眼鏡で接近すると
もう 付き合いできないんですね
「こんにちは」とも 言えなくなっちゃうんです
［様々な概念に洗脳されて 無理に良い人間に
なろうと努力する］これ いくつか例を出しますね
一番目の例は いろんな世の中の言ってることで
洗脳されちゃって
「俺は 良い人間になってやろう」と
努力するんです 無理をやるんです
だから 頭がおかしいよ
これは自分を愛することじゃないんです
もう一つ［世直しに努力して
世に迷惑な存在にもなる］
特に西洋的には 世直し 世直し
正義の味方
だから その子供たちに使っている
文学 漫画などなどは もう…
全部 正義の味方の話ばっかりで
子供たちは病気になるんです
［信仰する宗教の妄想概念に導かれて
自害的な行為もする］
宗教もそうやって
人を素直にさせないんです
「ああ こんにちは」と
言えない状態を作るんです
友達になっても
「一緒にご飯食べましょう」と言っても
「ええ こいつは仏教で私はイスラム教で…」
「すいませんね」と言うんです
できないんです
だって あれ食うな これ食うな…
と 言ってるんだからね
そこで どんな宗教も…
過激派だけじゃなくてね
自害的なことを教えてますよ
どんな宗教も
仏教も
「何だそれ？」と聞いたって
誰も分かってないんです
大日如来を経験したければ
「大日如来が現れてほしいな」と思うバカが
飲まず食わず 何年も
森の中で 山の上で すごい崖があるところで
何か 行をやってますよ
呪文を唱えたり
滝に打たれたり
ずーっと夜 何かどこかで
オープンにして 山の上でね
ずーっと座禅を組んで
呪文を唱えたり とか
自害的な行為でしょう？
それで脳が おかしくなったら
たまに 何か変な幻覚が見えます
で それは大日如来じゃないんですけど
何か ちょっと幻覚が起きたんです
で 幻覚だから
大したことないでしょう？
これで無理やり それを解説して
「ある日 私に突然 こんなことが起きましたよ」
と言って 宗派まで作っちゃうんですね
それで 後の連中が それに
なおさらストーリーを 加えて加えて…
病気ですよ
はっきり言えば
例えば そんなに
大日如来が すっごい奴なら
簡単に 顔を出せばいいでしょうに
みんなに「俺は 大日如来だからね
しっかりしなさいよ」と言ったら
みんな 信じられるでしょうに
こいつは 4年間 5年間 6年間
飲まず 食わず
いろんな行を やって
やりまくっちゃって
山を登ったり 下りたり
あれやこれやと ハチャメチャやったところで
何か頭の中 ちょっとおかしくなっただけで
それも「俺は大日如来だぞ」という
自己紹介もなくてね
だから 仏教の
いろいろ…妄想概念を作ってね
自害的な行為を させてるんです
それで 宗教と関係ない人も
［善人を演じ］るんですね
［良い人間だと社会から褒められて
認めてもらいたく］
［社会の不幸 不平 などを批判する］
ギャーギャー…
「こんなことが あってはならない」…
あれやこれやと
しゃべるわ しゃべるわ
だから「この人は素晴らしい人だ」と
社会が褒めてくれる と思ってるんです
リーダーに仕立てる と
思ってるんです
［自分の問題を隠して 他人の過ちを公にする］
人もいます　最近 よくありますね
マス…何とかで
ソーシャルメディアで
書きたい放題
人の悪口を書く
それが正しいかどうか
証明する必要もないんです
書けばいいんです
それでバカも…あれを読む連中は
「その通りだ」と思っちゃうんです
なんか 本当にアホな世界なんです
誰かが書いて 自分の携帯で
「○○さんが こういう
悪いことをしましたよ」と
それで「これで○○さんと○○さんは
すごく困ってるんだよ」と
で みんなは
「ああ そうですか」と
「やっぱりあの人は…」
と 思っちゃうんです
調べようともしない
それで 本人に聞いたら
「○○さん ○○さんが迷惑になった」と言っても
「その人は どこにいるのか？」と
「ええ これはプライバシーだから
言いませんよ」と　自分が作った名前だからね
これを読んで 乗るんだからね
だから特に ソーシャルメディアは
人を非難 侮辱するために
ものすごく 力を入れて
使ってるんですね
だからその 書くバカがね
「自分が善人になるんだ」と思ってるんです
それで　人をけなしたら
よくある精神的な病気なんです
ですから…
自分を愛する人は
Be normal　それだけ
はい
そこで［自己中心的］という
ポイントが ありますね
［誰もが自己中心的な気持ちを
持っているが］
［その考えに気づかない
落とし穴があります］
我々は みんな
自己中心的なんです
だから「自己中心的である」と
認めてほしいんです
みんな そうじゃなくて
カッコつけて…
「みんなのために
言ってるんではないか」
「ブッダの教えによると あなたのしゃべり方は
間違ってるんではないか」
「ブッダの教えから見れば…」
「あなたの生き方
間違ってるんではないか」と
だから そういうのに私が反応したら
大変なことになりますけどね
だから もともと人は自己中心的
だから 自分のしゃべることに気をつけて
「これは自己中心的だ」と
人を非難する前に
ものすごく 気をつけるんです
この非難は
外れる可能性は 90%
それで 自己中心的っていうことは いつでも
「自分が正しい」という前提なんです
これは どんな生命も持っている
ひとつのハンディ（障害）なんですね
どうしても「自分が正しい」
と 思っているんです
［主観で世を観るのは構わないが］
［「自分が正しい」という
前提を持っている限り］
［自分の主観は 当てにならない
ピント外れの 歪曲された思考になります］
だから
「私は ちょっと病気がありますよ」と
「私は 自分の考えることが正しい
と 思ってるんだよ」と…
いうことを覚えてないと
自分が何をやっても 大変なことになるんです
自分の知識 すべて
歪曲された 乱れた知識になります
これは 自己を愛することじゃないんです
［主観で世界を見て 自分に対して
嫌悪感を抱く時もあります］
ある特定の人々がいますね
自分の視点を 見ているんです
これも 自分の主観で見ているんです
見てみると 自分の希望があるでしょう？
いろいろ
自分では 実現できないけど
「あれ？あの人は成功している」
「あの人は成功している」
「あの人は見事にやっている」…
と 勝手に思うんです
勝手に思って
「それに比べて  私は何のことか」と
自己嫌悪に陥るんです
「何だこれは？」と
自分が…
テレビで ネットで
あれで これで
「あの人は 大成功だ」と 見たとしても
本当にどうか 分からんでしょうに
ある人が一生懸命 仕事をしているのを見たら
「あの人は 大成功だ」
その人の人生は
分からんでしょうに
［他人と自分を比較して見ることは
ほとんどの場合は 正解へと導かないのです］
決して 自分と他人を
比較しては いけないんですね
はい そういうことをやってるんだから
人々はね なかなか…
自分を愛することが
できなくなっているんです…
自分を大事にすることが…
自分を愛する ということは
あまりよくないんだけど
英語で self-compassion
自分を慈しむこと
「私は幸せでありますように」 と
これを 願えなくなっちゃうんです
「私は幸せでありますように
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように」と…
素直に念じられるならば
その人は すごく立派な人間なんです
へそ曲がりで
「あれ言うと気持ち悪いんだ」とかね
よく言うんです
相当 悪人なんですよ
だから 素直に美しく
「私は幸せでありますように」と 言える人は
「私の悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように」と…
素直に言えた人が
ものすごい 大物なんです
ただの 並の人間じゃないんです
だから今まで ずーっとしゃべったのは みんな
へそ曲がりの 醜い人間の性格なんです
それを 仏教は「これ 間違ってるんだから」
といって 直したいと思ってるんです　はい
はい それで
あまり難しくは ないんだから
経典にいきます［Mallikāsuttaṃ］という
（講演前半の Purisasuttaṃ と）同じ
Kosalasaṃyuttaṃ の
経典にありまして
［自分自身よりも好きな人はいますか？］
というテーマです
「私にとって
私よりも大事な人がいるんだよ」と…
「いますか？」
というテーマがあって
マッリカー Mallikā というお妃と
旦那がコーサラ国王なんです
その二人は
ものすごい仲良し夫婦なんです
そこで コーサラ国王が
宮殿の二階で
風が 吹くところで
窓を開けて 外を見ながら
そばに マッリカー妃も座っている
そばに いるんですね
旦那さんと一緒に
仲良しで
それで お互いに
恋人みたいな感じで いろいろ
まあ 恋しているでしょうね
だから 国王が聞くんです
「君に この世の中でね
君より 自分よりも…」
好きな人　いわゆる 好ましい
「大事な人がいますか？」と…
自分の命よりも大事な
これもう 夫婦で
いろいろ お互い…
恋の話なんかを 恋人同士で
しゃべってるときでしょう？
そのときは必ず
嘘ばっかり言ってるでしょう？
これは だいたい恋人同士で
結婚する前だからね
何ひとつも
本当のことは言わないね
で この国王が
期待しているんです 答えを
「私には 私の命よりも
王様の方が大事ですよ」と
でも この女性は
「あのね どう調べても…」
「私には 一番好きな存在は
私ですよ」と
他より全然 好きだ と…
言ったら
機嫌が悪くなっちゃったんです
「何という ひどい女だ」
と 思ったでしょうね
でも マッリカー妃は
バカじゃないんです
ものすごくブッダと
会ったり 説法を聞いたり
コーサラ王よりも マッリカー夫人とお釈迦様の
関係が かなり強いんです
だから マッリカー妃が聞くんです
「はい あなたに聞きますよ」と
「あなたには 自分より
とっても好きな人は 誰かいるんですか？」と…
言ったら「ええと…」
「ああ やっぱり」「そういえば
私の一番好きな存在は 私ですよ」と
それでまあ「お互い様でしょう」と
いうことになったんです　しかし…
マッリカー夫人の
この ものすごい智慧
国王が 怒れないんです
理性に
だからそれを 自慢げに
お釈迦様に報告したんです
夫婦でこうやって話をしたときに
こんなこんな出来事が起きましたよ と…
言ったら お釈迦様は
「その通りだ」と  答えたんです
‘‘Sabbā disā anuparigamma cetasā,
Nevajjhagā piyataramattanā kvaci;
Evaṃ piyo puthu attā paresaṃ,
Tasmā na hiṃse paramattakāmo’’ti. という…
教えを 教えたんです
はい
で これ
翻訳を コピペしたもので
［すべての方角を心によって訪ねても］
［どこであれ 自分より愛しい者には
まったく行き当たらなかった］
お釈迦様は ちょっと
拡大するんです
この存在の中で どう見ても
「自分にとって 自分自身より
愛しいものは ありません」と
［そのように 他の者たちによっても
それぞれの自己が愛しいのである］
だから そこで
バカみたく 止まるんじゃなくて
私のこと 全宇宙の中で
「私も 一番好きだよ」と
だから…何だということになる？
だから…
「他の生命も
同じ気持ちを 持ってるんだよ」と
だから どんな生命にも
一番 愛しい存在は 自分なんです
だから それで「セルフコンパッションについて
しゃべりなさい」と…
頼んだところで
何か問題があるんです
お釈迦様の答えは
もっと道徳的で
［そのように 他の者たちによっても
それぞれの自己が愛しいのである］
［それゆえ 自己を欲する者は
他者を害するなかれ］と
自分を愛する法を 教えたんです
「私のことが 大好きだ」
と 言ったら
こちらにいる生命も
「自分のことが 大好きだ」と
それを認めたら
「何だ あんたは？」とかね
「何だ この犬は？」とかね
そういう人は
自分を害しているんです
だから 自分を愛する
自分を慈しむ方法っていうのは…
自分中心に考えるんです
どんな生命も 自分のこと 第一です
これ 現実だから 事実だから
認めるしかないでしょう？
それでも認めない人々
いるでしょう？
「動物って 何ぞや？」と
「害虫って 何ぞや？」と
「全部 殺しちゃえ」と
それって自分を慈しむこと？
［自分を大事にするならば
他に害を与えてはならないという］
［他の生命も自分と等しいのだ
という戒めの言葉です］だから…
「セルフコンパッション」あるいは
「自分を慈しむ」ということは
第1ステップは「すべての生命は 平等で
自分と同じだ」と 見ることなんです
それで 自分が
守られているんです
［自分のこと 自分の存在が嫌いと感じることは
常識ではありません］
ときどき いますね
現代社会では
「私は 私のこと 大嫌いだ」と
あれ 常識じゃないんです
ありえないんです
どこかで変なんです
ありえない
［怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨みなどの感情に
刺激されて 妄想にふけった生き方の結果です］
だから ずーっと 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨みなどで
妄想して して…
他 何もできなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると「私は 私のこと大嫌い」
と 言うんです
言ったとたん それは「あなたは精神的に
病気です」ということです
だから「私は幸せでありますように」…
「生きとし生けるものが
幸せでありますように」という人は いつでも…
ほほえんでいるんです
いつでも 笑っているんです
みじんも心に 病気がないんです
はい
次の経典がありまして ［自護］…
自護経 というんですね
番号入れるの
忘れちゃったんだけどね
それも コーサラ王が聞いた質問に
答えたんですね
「どうやって自分を守るのか」「自分を
どうやって大事にするのか？」と聞いたところで
‘‘Kāyena saṃvaro sādhu,
sādhu vācāya saṃvaro;
Manasā saṃvaro sādhu,
sādhu sabbattha saṃvaro;
Sabbattha saṃvuto lajjī,
rakkhitoti pavuccatī’’ti.
自分を護る と
［身による防護はよきものである
言葉による防護はよきものである］
［意による防護はよきものである
あらゆるところの防護はよきものである］
あらゆるところっていうのは
例えば 身口意ですね　全部…
saṃvara っていうのは
「防護」というよりは「気をつける」…
「コントロール」
［あらゆるところを防護された］…
有恥（うじ）？
何と言った？これは
（読み方 分かりますか？）ん？
（うじ かな？）
有恥（うじ）ですかね？
（ゆうじ）ゆうじ
まあ とにかく
「恥を感じる人」ですね
この「恥」っていうのは 仏教でいう
「慚愧（ざんぎ）」のことなんです
「汚い 品格のないことは やりたくない」
という プライドなんですね
で そのプライドを持っている人は
［『守られている』と言われるのである」］と
だから 自分を慈しむならば
言葉に気をつける…
身体の行為に気をつける…
考えることに気をつける
みんな それを放っておくでしょう？
だから…
とんでもない精神的な病気になるんです
余計なことを考えてはいかん いつでも
思考をコントロールしなくちゃいかん
だから 妄想に頭が行くならば
もうハチャメチャ…
慈悲の言葉を唱えて 唱えて 唱えまくって
心を守った方がいいんです…
他の思考が 割り込まないように
その人が「自分を守っている人」
に なります　はい
はい そこでまた コーサラ国王が
政治家だからね
警備に対して セキュリティに対して
結構 頑張ってるんです
国王だから ものすごく大量の人々が
国王を守っているんです
軍隊がいて
象隊もいますから…象の軍隊
馬隊　弓…
いろいろで
で 国王がある日
自分をどれほど厳しく守られているのかと
見たんですね
見たら「あれ？」
「こんなので 守られたことにならんよ」と
騎馬隊が 動いていたからといって
宮殿の中でも
軍人が あちらこちらにいたからといって
守られたことにならない と
例えば 今もね
そういうセキュリティ あるでしょうに
大統領のそばにも
5、6人 すごい射撃訓練していて
トップの人々 いるでしょう？
そいつが 自分のピストルで
そのまま撃っちゃえば どうなる？
守られたことには
ならんでしょう？
どうやって「この人に殺されない」
と いうふうに…
約束ないんですよ
そんなのは意味がない と
これは錯覚だ と…
セキュリティシステムは
［しかし 身体で悪行為をしたり
悪語を話したり］
［悪思考したりするならば
自分は内から崩壊していくのです］
だから 周りで みんなが機関銃を持って
四方八方 見ていたからといって
自分の身口意が 間違っているならば
中から崩壊していくんです
［自分の生き方の中に自己破壊の原因が
潜んでいることに注意するべき］ですね　はい
で 次の経典は
「自分を慈しみなさい」という
テーマなんですね［Love thyself (yourself)］
‘‘Attānañce piyaṃ jaññā,
na naṃ pāpena saṃyuje;
Na hi taṃ sulabhaṃ hoti,
sukhaṃ dukkaṭakārinā.
まず 私の訳を言いますよ
Attānañce piyaṃ jaññā,
「自分のことを好きだ」と 思うならば
問題は それも思ってないでしょう？
みんな
相当 病気でしょう？
だから 前の経典で言ったことを
覚えなくちゃあかん
客観的に調べると
「自分のことが 一番愛しい」なんです
それを発見したならば
na naṃ pāpena saṃyuje;
自分を悪と交じったことは しないでください
自分の命を 悪に交じった生き方…
「してはいけません」と だって
自分のこと 大事でしょうに
Na hi taṃ sulabhaṃ hoti,
sukhaṃ dukkaṭakārinā.
世の中 逆に生きてるんです
悪いことばっかり しまくって
幸福になりたがるんです
例えば 選挙のときは
いろんな人の悪口 批判ばっかり言って
自分が勝って 幸せになると
思っています
そうはならない と思いますよ
世の中  会社であろうが 社会であろうが
国際状況であろうが
いつでも 悪行為ばっかりするんです
悪行為ばっかりして
自分が幸せになりたい と思っているんです
ロシアが悪行為して
ロシアが 幸せになりたがっているんです
ウクライナが悪行為をして
また 幸せになりたがっているんです
お釈迦様は
「それって難しいよ」と
「そんなの難しいよ」と
例えば お金を横領して
金持ちになるとか？
なりません
すぐバレちゃって
「何で そんなに金があるのかい？」と
「どうやって あなた
外国でこんなものを買ったのか？」と
バレたら…
幸福になるわけじゃないんですね
だから お釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
「自分を 大好きであるならば」…
「悪と 交わるなよ」と
学者の訳はね［もし自己を愛しいものと
知ったならば それを悪と結びつけるべからず］
［なぜなら かの安楽は悪をなす者によっては
たやすく得られないからである］
はい　次に行きます
［自分が何を連れて逝くの］
という テーマですね
‘‘Antakenādhipannassa,
jahato mānusaṃ bhavaṃ;
Kiñhi tassa sakaṃ hoti,
kiñca ādāya gacchati;
Kiñcassa anugaṃ hoti,
chāyāva anapāyinī  これは質問ですね
［死魔に追いつかれ］
「死魔」って 別に
神秘的に考えないでください
まあ 普通の「死」なんですね
［人としての生存を捨てる者 彼には
何が自分のものとして存続するであろうか］
もう人が 死にかけてるんです
もうそろそろ 死ぬんです
はい「この人の 持って行けるものは
何ですか？」と 聞いてるんです
［〔来生に〕何を持って行くであろうか］
［何が彼に 去ることのない影のごとくに
付き従うであろうか］
で
影は いつでも 人と一緒にいるような感じで
人が死んじゃっても…
「あの世に 行くものは何ですか？」と
いう質問なんですね
はい
ブッダの答え
‘‘Ubho puññañca pāpañca,
yaṃ macco kurute idha;
Tañhi tassa sakaṃ hoti,
tañca ādāya gacchati;
Tañcassa anugaṃ hoti,
chāyāva anapāyinī.
［死すべき人がこの世でなす 善悪双方］
［彼には それが自分のものとして存続する］
やった善行為 悪行為は
一緒に行きますよ と
［〔来生に〕それを持って行く］
［それが彼に 去ることのない
影のごとくに付き従う］
だから これって難しくない
善悪は 心でやってるんだから
その影響は いつでも
心に あるんです
だから 死んでも 次に その心は
その影響を持って行くんです
だから 人は自分のことを慈しむならば
「善行為しなさいよ」と
悪行為も 善行為も やっぱり同じ感じで
あの世に行きますからね
だから まあ
「善行為しなさい」
ということになります　はい
それで 次の偈も 同じ経典にありますよ
［Be good］
Tasmā　ですから
kareyya kalyāṇaṃ　良いことやってよ と
nicayaṃ samparāyikaṃ
ええと
［それゆえ 未来の富として善をなすべし］
Puññāni paralokasmiṃ,
patiṭṭhā honti pāṇina’’nti.
［生き物たちにとって 功徳は
他界における 拠り所となる］と
だから「人は善行為するべき」
と いうことはね
「自分の財産とは 善行為である」と
はい
はい それで
大体 終わりになってきます
［Appamādasuttaṃ］
という経典が ありまして
これも質問なんですね
お釈迦様に聞くんですね
この世で幸福になるための…
［この世で 又あの世で幸福になるための
たった一つの法がありますか？］と
怠けた質問ですね
八正道は 八もあるんだから
面倒くさい と
八もある
「ああ 面倒くさい」と
それで コーサラ王が
「たった一つ ないんですか？」と
この世で幸せになる
あの世で幸福になる
お釈迦様は答えたんです
‘‘Atthi kho, mahārāja, eko dhammo
yo ubho atthe samadhiggayha tiṭṭhati
［大王よ 両方の利益を得て］
［住立するような一法は…一つの法は
存在します］ありますよ と
一個だけで
全部やってくれるんだよ と
diṭṭhadhammikañceva atthaṃ
samparāyikañcā’’ti.［〔すなわち〕…］
［現世と来世の利益を］と
はい
それが［不放逸］なんです
‘‘Appamādo kho, mahārāja, eko dhammo,
yo ubho atthe samadhiggayha tiṭṭhati–
diṭṭhadhammikañceva atthaṃ
samparāyikañcāti.
［大王よ 不放逸が 両方の利益を得て
住立するような一つの法なのです］
［〔すなわち〕現世と来世の利益を］
現世で幸福になりたければ
死後も幸福になりたければ
不放逸ですね
これ一つだけ 不放逸というのは
sati ― 気づき のことなんです
「これをやれば どうですか？」と
例えがありますよ
hatthipadaṃ tesaṃ aggamakkhāyati
これ ちょっと省略しています
［密林に住んでいる全ての生命の足跡は
象の足跡の中に入る］
森で いろんな動物の足跡
あるでしょう？
どんな動物の足跡も
象の足跡の中に入ります
全部 小さいんです
象の足跡は 大きいんです
［…入るように 不放逸はこの世で あの世で
幸福に達する一つの法になります］と
だからすべて 自分を慈しみたければ
あれこれ まあただ…
「気づきの実践」なんですね
だから来世は 信じても 信じなくても
どうでもいいんだけど
この世で幸福になりますからね
プログラムとか変えれば　うん
終わりですかね それで
うん
はい そこで
［自分を慈しむならば］
人は 自分のことを
大事に思っているならば
［怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨みなどで
こころを汚さない］
きったないでしょう？
自分が汚れたら
［他の生命を
自分と平等だと思って生きる］
［差別を捨てる］
［こころを清らかにする］やっぱり
汚れた心だったら 気持ち悪いんじゃない？
［執着を減らす］
［感情の奴隷になって
生きることを止める］
［妄想にふけることを止める］
［理性と知恵を育てる］という項目で
自分を慈しむことができます
まあ大体 仏教でおっしゃっている
戒律を守ることやら…
すべて 自分を慈しむことなんです
私が瞑想したからといって「お父さんが
解脱に達した」ということは ありえないんです
はい そういうことで
［自分のことを大事にする」というのは
ずーっと仏教で教えていることなんです 悟りは…
自分で悟らなくちゃあかんでしょう？
煩悩は 自分の煩悩でしょう？
これは自分で絶たなくちゃあかんです
「お父さん 私の煩悩を なくしてくれ」と
それは できないんです
そういうことで まあ
ほとんどの仏教の教えは
セルフコンパッション ― 自分を慈しむ
ということで　だから解脱まで 自分を…
進んで進んで 向上させてもっていくんです
はい 以上です
（はい ありがとうございました）
（ええと 今日は4時半までですので
若干 お時間がございます）
（20分ぐらい ありますけど）
（何か 今日のお話に関連して…）
（あるいは関連しなくてもいいんですけど 何か
質問ある方 いらっしゃいますか？）
（挙手していただければ）
（では中段のところのお二人…）
（手を挙げてらっしゃいますね 今
マイクを持って向かいます）
では 先にこちらの方
（今日は ありがとうございました）
（良い行いを しようとするときに）
（照れてしまってまして）
（例えば お年寄りに席を譲るとか）
（あるいは 親孝行しようとしたときに
照れてしまって）
（それができない ということが
よくあるんですが）
（それは 仏教では どういうふうに扱えば
いいんでしょうか？）簡単です
完璧 悪人です
（偽善ということでしょうか？）
いいえ 悪人です　偽善ではないんです
そんなに…
そんなに自我を張る？
良いことだったら
やればいいだけの話でしょう？
だから 素直じゃないでしょう？
頭の中で
自我で 自我で 自我で
ものすごい悪思考に もう…
凝ってしまって
こういう質問は 私も聞いて聞いて
昔から聞いてるでしょうに
こんなこと言われて
「ちょっと照れちゃいますよ」と
いまだに聞いている
その同じ質問を
そこで あまりにも自我だから
自分が良い人間だ と思っているんです
だから「ちょっと照れちゃった」とかね
お母さんに「こんにちは ありがとう」
と 言うと「ちょっと照れちゃった」とかね
だから 生きる喜びを知らない
こういう人々は
ものすごい 自分の殻を作って
自分の地獄を作って
苦しんでいるんです
なんで 悪行為するときは
照れないんですかね？
良いことをするときだけでしょう？
それは
痴漢をしようとするとき とか
友達とバンバン「じゃあ酒飲みましょう」
「はい どうぞ」「はいどうぞ」とかね
そのときは照れませんね
で「あんた 1曲歌ってください」
といったら 最低なんです 音痴で
そこで 肉体も
こんな汚い格好にして
マイクを持って歌うでしょう？
そのとき照れないでしょう？
誰に向かって
それを言うんですかね？…
「善行為するときだけ
照れちゃうんです」
だから 善行為するとき照れる人は
悪行為するときは 堂々と
「私は勇気がある人間だ」と
「恥ずかしいものは 何もない」
「前に出て活動するんだ」と…
言って 悪行為をするんです
ですから…
「善行為をするとき 照れちゃう」
ということが…
私が言ったことです…
悪人です
これはもう 優しい言葉では
答えられないんです
で
何のこともなく「当たり前」
というふうにやればね
私は 1回 2回 あったんだけど
すごく体調が悪くなっちゃって
歩けなくなっちゃって
ちょっと しゃがんじゃったんですね
で 頭がおかしくなって
そうすると…
周りを行く人々は
「ああ この人 調子が悪い」と 分かったんです
そうしたら さっさと来て
「大丈夫ですか？大丈夫ですか？」
「何をすればよろしい？」と
何のことなく聞くんでしょうに
そちらに照れは 感じなかったんです
親孝行するとき照れる…
信じられない
あなた そういう私の言葉を
「すごく厳しい」と 思わないで…
その通りに理解してみてください
その方が いいんです
あるいは一人一人
「私は 何をやるとき照れる？」…
「何をやるとき照れない？」
とかね…見てみれば
「良い行為をやるときだけ 照れる」
「悪行為やってるときは 堂々と胸を張って
やっちゃう」という 性格があるんです
だから
「自分を愛する」というプログラムを
実行してないから…
大体 そういう現象というのは
日本では 普通だと思います
外国 どんな外国でも
それは全然…
照れなんて 一切ない
人を助けるときでも…
親の面倒を見るときでも
まあ ドカンドカンと…
やっちゃいますよ
だから 日本に住んでいる外国人でもね
何かいいこと あったらすぐ「お母ちゃん
こういうことがありましたよ」と 報告する
うまくいかなかったら
それも言う
で なんとかお金を送って
助けてあげたりもする
それは世間では 普通ですけどね
私は昔から そういう「そんなこと言っても
照れちゃいますよ」というね
例えば お年寄りに座席をあげる
何のことなく 立てばいいでしょう？
自我が割り込んで
「立ったら 何か…」
「何か マズいなぁ」とかね
悪人でしょう？
私は あげたことありますよ 別に
ときどき私の方が 年上ですよ
人を見たら ちょっと何か調子が悪い
そうしたら…
何のことなく立ち上がって
別なところに行くんです
「はい どうぞ」
と 言わないんです
ただ「俺は降りたいよ」という態度をとって
立ち上がるんです
「ああ 面倒くさい」「俺は立って
それから降りますよ」という感じで
そうすると 隣のおじさんが
「ああ よかった 座りますよ」と
それだけ
そんな単純なことで
「立つとマズいなぁ 人に何と思われる…」
人は何も思わないよ？
人が 自分のことばっかり見張って…
「この人は 何するのか？」
とか やってないんです
まあ私の場合 あるんだけど
頭いかれてる人々は…
何から何まで 私が…
手を上げても じーっと見て
手を下げても じーっと見て
何か カップを取ったら じーっと見て
水を飲んだら
何口飲んだ と計算までして…
まあ そういうことはあるんだけどね
だから私は
そういう人々というのは
祝福が入らない ということを
知ってるんだから…まあ無視するんです
私をとことん いじめて いじめて
私のプライバシーまで侵害して
私を管理して コントロールして
幸せになると 思ってるんですね
なりません 幸せに
そういうのは末期状態で 治らない方々で
世の中 そうじゃないんです 大体…
人が何やってるのか と見て
まあ あっち見るんでしょうに
だから 電車で
自分が立ったから といって
「ああ すごい人！年寄りに座席を譲りました」
「ああ すごい！」ないでしょう？そんなの
自分のお父さんに
プレゼントを あげたからといって
「ああ すごい！」「あなた 本当？」
で 会社で話題になる？
「あなた お父さんにプレゼントあげた？」
「ああ すごいなぁ」
「これはテレビに出さなくちゃ」と…
何 考えてるんですかね？
はい そういう自我があるんだからね
完璧「悪」で 固まっている場合は
「善行為は し難い」と
お釈迦様は おっしゃってるんです
そういう偈もあります
自分の幸福になることは
「やりたくない」と
でも 自分が地獄に落ちることだったら
「進んで やっちゃいますよ」と
それも お釈迦様の言葉なんです
ダンマパダにあります
Yaṃ ve hitañ ca sādhuñ ca
– taṃ ve Parama dukkaraṃ.
(Dhammapada163)
自分の幸福になることだったら
もう やり辛くて やり辛くて
何で そうなるんですかね？
自分のためになるでしょうに
これって 子供が
宿題を嫌がるような感じでしょうに
子供が 宿題ではなく
ゲームやりたい と思った場合はね
大人になっても
そんな気持ちでいるんですかね？
はい ちょっと長くしゃべって
しまいましたけど 大体…
そういう問題は
日本社会にありますから
そこを理解して
頑張った方がいいと思います
（ありがとうございました）
（では もうひと方 お願いします）
（仏教は お釈迦様は 「苦集滅道」を
おっしゃったと思うんですけれども）
（「滅」というところは
渇愛を滅するために…）
（と いうことだと思うんですが その次には
八正道が出てくると思うんですが）
（最初はどうしても「滅」と「道」の
関係が 分からなかったんですね）
（どうして 渇愛を滅するためには
八つもやらなくちゃいけないのか と）
（そこでもう
分からなかったんですけども）
（さっきのコーサラ王のお話にも「一つの法を
やれば あなたは幸せになれます」それが…）
（「Appamāda 不放逸」
ということだった と思うんですけれども）
（私にとっては 不放逸をするためには
やっぱり八正道が少しずつでもできないと）
（不放逸もできないんじゃないかな
と思いまして 要するに仏教っていうのは…）
（八正道を 少しずつでも すべて自分の中で
完成していかなきゃいけないよ という…）
（教えなのでしょうか？）
まあ だから
そう決まってないんです
今日の経典で「不放逸で全部OKだ」
と言ってるんだから その通りです 別に
（「不放逸だけ完成すればもう それでOKだ」
というお釈迦様の教えなんですか？）うん
（不放逸を完成するためには 八正道すべてが
できないと…）また ぐるぐる回るんだから
何でそうやって回るんですかね？
八正道を完成しなくちゃいけない
で 八正道を完成できないんだから
じゃあ不放逸をやる
不放逸をやるためには八正道をやる…
どこまで回るんですかね？
「不放逸を実践すれば 仏道は完成だ」
と おっしゃっているんだから
その人には全部
他は管轄外でしょうに
お釈迦様は 涅槃に入るほんのちょっと前にも
言ったのは 不放逸でしょう？
「これを守りなさいよ」と
だから 不放逸を守る人は
八正道を守っているんです
そんなに ややこしい説明は
やりたくない
不放逸をやった人は
八正道をやっているんです
（ありがとうございました）うん
（はい それでは ちょうど
時間になりましたので これで…）
（終了したいと思います
ありがとうございました）
（祝福の…）
（普段のでも よろしいですかね？）うん
では 祈願文章を唱えて
終了したいと思います
Dukkhappattā ca niddukkhā
Bhayappattā ca nibbhayā
Sokapattā ca nissokā
Hontu sabbepi pāṇino
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
おそれて悩む生命がおそれなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい ありがとうございます
（皆様 ありがとうございました）
（以上をもちまして 本日の初期仏教月例講演会
終了とさせていただきます）
（どなた様も お忘れ物なさいませんように
お気をつけてお帰りください）
（なお 中野駅をご利用の方は
歩道の左側を通行いただき…）
（前方からの歩行者の妨げとならぬよう
ご配慮お願いいたします）
（本日は ご来場いただきまして
誠にありがとうございました）